Здрастуйте, мої хороші!
Доброго ранку! Зі святом!
Привіт! Ви на репетиції?
Доброго ранку!
Починаємо, так?
Добрий день!
Я радий бачити вас.
Я стою в залі на прем'єрі
і зустрічаю глядачів.
Хтось спеціально збирався,
хтось заклопотаний,
вони ідуть швидко, вітаються,
ідуть у гардероб, ідуть в залу, сідають.
І я дивлюсь на людей,
які виходять із зали.
Це інші люди, у них змінились очі:
у когось вони заплакані, у когось —
усміхнені, але це — інші люди.
І я думаю, що поки людина буде
людиною мислячою,
театр буде потрібен.
Сашо, а на вході сітілайт повісили, так?
Нормально він виглядає?
На сцені я бачу.
Так буває в нас у лісі — не завжди тихо.
Одного разу я був запрошений
на день народження до свого друга,
до режисера мінського театру,
який влаштував неймовірний
перформанс для своїх друзів.
Він у себе на дачі під Мінськом
викопав маленьке озерце,
збудував сцену, запросив друзів і поставив
там зі своїм театром «Чайку» Чехова.
От тоді у нас заклалося, що можна
на природі робити якісь неймовірні речі.
Так з'явилась «Лісова пісня»,
потім «Майська ніч».
Це вже репертуарні вистави,
які тільки там можуть гратися.
Ми почали відкривати
літній театральний сезон,
закривати його в кінці літа,
відкривати осінній тут.
Взагалі, наш театр не припиняє працювати нон-стоп,
тому що кожна сцена має свій репертуар.
На сцені кафе-театру десь десять вистав,
на основній сцені — десь 17 вистав,
на сцені під сценою — десять,
на сцені під дахом — теж десь десяток.
Якщо зібрати докупи — десь 57 вистав.
Хочеш якусь сучасну річ — будь ласка,
хочеш драму — будь ласка.
Хочеш просто музичну виставу,
щоб відпочити, — приходь.
На будь-який смак у тебе є вибір.
І це нам дає нам змогу...
Щоб подивитися якусь виставу,
не треба обов'язково їхати
до Києва на «Золоті ворота».
Ми «Золоті ворота» зробимо тут.
Микола Гурович Куліш —
це наш патрон, це херсонець,
який працював, жив, творив у Херсоні.
І, до речі, цікава історія
із прапором Євросоюзу.
До нас польський театр привіз
цей прапор на «Мельпомену» 2014 року.
І сказав: «Ми з вами.
Ми хочемо, щоб ви були».
Театр їздить з гастролями закордон,
не чекаючи від держави
грошей чи від міністерства.
Ми беремо участь у багатьох
фестивалях, зокрема міжнародних.
А головне досягнення в тому,
що херсонський глядач любить свій театр.
— Здрастуйте!
— Добрий день!
Скажіть, будь ласка,
а як доїхати завтра туди до вас?
У ліс? Треба в касі купити квиток,
там можна придбати квиток і на автобус.
І все, і ви приїжджаєте.
Тут, як ви бачите, природна кучугура,
як кажуть у нас на Херсонщині,
і ми використали її як глядацьку залу,
тому що цей схил природний,
якраз дуже зручно —
видно все на сцені.
Як бачите, ми не чіпали дерев.
Мені кажуть: «Давай тут дах робити».
Я кажу: «Ні, тут повинні зірки бути,
має інша атмосфера [панувати]».
Ми нічого тут не рушили,
ми дуже обережно ставимось до природи.
Ми тут граємо дитячі вистави,
де показуємо, що таке ліс,
як його треба берегти,
тобто займаємося
ще й екологічним вихованням.
У «Лісовій пісні» в нас Водяник
і потерчата в воді, їх кидають,
і мокрий Лукаш, якого лякають,
вискакує звідси,
тому все абсолютно натуральне,
використовуються всі можливості.
Я просто все життя працюю в культурі,
у театрі — 31 рік.
Сім років я працював директором
сільського будинку культури.
Закінчивши училище, маючи червоний
диплом, я поїхав «піднімати село» —
у ті часи нас так виховували.
Для мене це були університети,
і я в селі точно бачив
(мені тоді було 24 роки),
я приїхав у село директором будинку культури,
величезний такий будинок культури,
мабуть як мій театр майже,
але абсолютно пустий —
нічого не було, велике село.
І я побачив, що як ми
почали щось робити —
студію театральну створили,
диско-клуб, ще щось —
як село перетворювалось
— воно чекало культури.
Вона йому була потрібна,
тому що купа молоді.
Але тоді там була робота,
діти залишалися в селі,
на дискотеку чотири рази на тиждень
приходили 300 людей.
Це говорить про те, що була молодь,
їй було цікаво бути в селі,
не їхати в місто, не тікати.
От мені дуже хочеться, щоб сьогодні
почало розвиватися наше українське село для того,
щоб не тільки в місті були доступні
блага для молоді — оце найголовніше.
Креативні індустрії сьогодні можуть
бути додатковим поштовхом у розвитку,
а там долучається театральний туризм,
потім ще щось, ще щось.
Якщо критична маса
позитивних людей хочуть змін,
і не просто хочуть, а щось роблять —
це може рухати розвиток міста буквально вперед.
Шановні добродії, запрошуємо вас до зали!
Автобус доїхав, люди доходять,
і ми починаємо.
Ви подивилися, що як,
щоб потім у вас все вийшло?
— Ви тут мабуть...
— Ми тут постоїмо, чи ми ще щось?..
Ні, не будете, сюди ближче просто,
так буде нормально.
А ви ж у нас ще не були тут,
так, чи були минулого року?
Ні, ні, не були. Це вперше.
Тільки бачили фотографії.
Я думаю, що це єдина
така локація в Україні.
Так, нема ні в кого.
Ми в цьому 100% [впевнені].
У нас багато речей у театрі,
яких ні в кого немає.
У мене п'ятеро дітей:
два сина, три доньки.
Я зібрав сім'ю,
брата свого рідного і кажу:
«Ну, давайте спробуємо зрозуміти,
що таке зелений туризм».
І тут ми зараз закладаємо парк
«Чотири сезони», бачите?
От уявіть собі, це вже тут росте три роки,
а от було все, як отам, — пустир.
Нічого не було взагалі,
як ми почали.
Тут буде парк, ми вже його розбили,
обриси його видно трошки.
Ми намагаємось тут
створити куточок Херсонщини.
Це справжня рокита, яка в нас
росте в пустелі і квітне дуже красиво.
Там — пижмо.
Тут багато рослин
із Асканійського дендропарку,
тому що я дружу з Асканією-Новою,
з унікальним місцем, яке в нас є.
І директор там — унікальний чоловік,
завдяки якому було збережено те, що там є:
і степ цей, і навколо нього все.
Це готель невеличкий.
Автобуси їдуть із Запоріжжя, Одеси,
Миколаєва, з нашої Херсонської області.
У нас Генічеськ, наприклад,
на відстані 250-ти кілометрів,
але люди їдуть, отже, це цікаво.
І ми вирішили, що треба розвивати
й далі подієвий туризм.
Добрий вечір!
Ми раді вас вітати на нашій лісовій сцені.
Ви знаєте, що наша вистава,
яку ви дивитиметесь сьогодні,
йде в рамках ХХІІ Міжнародного
театрального фестивалю «Мельпомена Таврії».
Хай він невеличкий цього року —
всього 11 театрів, 11 вистав,
але літературна складова дуже велика.
Я запрошую вас, херсонці, завтра
о 10-й годині в самому театрі,
де буде читка п'єси білоруського
драматурга Андрія Курєйчика...
Андрюша, ти де? Піднімися,
щоб героя Білорусі бачили!
Ти вже тут чи ні? От!
Це — майбутній міністр культури
Білорусі у вигнанні, я кажу.
Я дивлюсь на свою країну
очима своїх друзів.
Того ж Тунджера [Джюдженоглу, турецького драматурга],
я зустрів в аеропорту, везу в машині,
а він каже: «Ви українці, ви такі розумні!
У вас така культура, ви така нація,
у вас такі поля!
У вас таке все!
У вас такий потенціал!»
Мені так хочеться, щоб ми, українці,
про свою країну говорили:
«У нас в Україні все є».
І буде точно!
Ми — національний театр, тому що
ми відстоюємо національну ідею.
Ми сьогодні на півдні України, на кордоні тут.
І робимо все для того, щоб у Херсоні
не питали, якою мовою [йде] вистава.
І це вже є велике досягнення.
Ми теж на фронті.
От прийшло 700 людей до зали:
різні за релігійними уподобаннями,
за партійною приналежністю, за віком.
І вони сіли в залі, і за дві години
ми з ними, як маги, щось створили.
Вони стали спільнотою.
Ми їх змусили або плакати, або сміятися.
І ми їх зібрали — вони розуміють,
що ми тепер суспільство, громада.
Ми воюємо за душі людей,
які щодня приходять сюди в театр.
І може це інколи більше,
ніж з автоматами десь бути.